abdul mohamed shawky soll seine ehefrau
in münchen ermordet und ihre leiche
unter dem bett der kinder versteckt
haben ein abscheuliches verbrechen
der tatverdächtige ist auf der flucht
und steht jetzt auf der most wanted
liste von europol kelkheim und chef
alexander berichten
es ist die liste der meist gesuchten
straftäter in europa und jetzt steht
abdullah mohammed tokio mit drauf
europol fahndet mit diesem bild nach dem
mann der im november des vergangenen
jahres seine ehefrau brutal ermordet
haben soll und seitdem auf der flucht
ist
der fall hatte bundesweit schlagzeilen
gemacht ok wird vorgeworfen seine 34
jährige ehefrau in münchen ramersdorf
kaltblütig ab gestochen zu haben und die
leiche im bettkasten seiner kinder
versteckt zu haben achtung fahndung
hatte bereits darüber berichtet und
exklusiv mit der schwester der
ermordeten gesprochen uns hat dieses
schicksalsschlags herz getroffen aber
was auch genauso schlimm ist dass der
mörder meiner schwester immer noch frei
herum läuft dass er sein leben ganz
normal leben kann das nicht gegen ihn
unternommen wird
fast täglich kommt beim absatz familie
hier zum südfrüchte hier wurde die junge
mutter bekam heute begleiten wir ihre
schwester nadja bei diesem schwierigen
weg naja wie geht es ihnen jetzt nach
fast einem jahr nach dieser
schrecklichen tat je mehr zeit vergeht
desto mehr vermisst man sie und dann
kommt jährlich ihre geburtstage und
jetzt leider auch der todestag was uns
halt am schwersten fällt einfach und wie
ist das jetzt wenn du jetzt hier am grab
ist was das viel zu tun wenn ich ehrlich
bin wir nicht hier am grab und dann
fühle ich mich sehr sehr verbunden zu er
dann ist wieder diese verbundenheit die
wir vor allem wir zwei hatten also ich
habe mein leben hier und sie liegt unter
diesem grab das ist halt einfach
[Musik]
es tut sehr weh man hat einfach diesen
herzschmerz der einfach nicht vergehen
will
und an den täter hat die schwester von
ben usher noch eine ganz persönliche
nachricht
aktuell monat wie kannst du so unsere
familien glück zerstören wir haben noch
zusammengesessen wir haben zusammen
gegessen gespielt gelacht wie konntest
du das den kindern meiner schwester
antun wie kannst du das meinen eltern
antun
mittlerweile weiß ich dass seine tat
geplant war du hast wochen zuvor schon
nach einem ticket nach afghanistan
gesucht und egal wo du bist ich frage
dich denkst du wirklich du kommst mit so
einer straftat einfach so davon
wo ist absolut okay wer hat ihn nach der
tat am 17 november vergangenen jahres
gesehen wer weiß vielleicht wo er sich
genau im ausland aufhält die polizei hat
eine belohnung von 10.000 euro
ausgesetzt für hinweise die zur
ergreifung des täters führen durch die
fahndung wie europol liegt das foto nun
an allen europäischen grenzen vor
ja und der fall abdi mohamed shawky hat
durch die aktuellen entwicklungen
afghanistan natürlich eine ganz
besondere aktualität denn vielleicht ist
der mann längst aus afghanistan geflohen
und zurück hier in europa und irgendwo
hier untergetaucht deshalb fragt die
kripo wer kann angaben
zum aktuellen aufenthaltsort von puky
machen hinweise nimmt die polizei unter
089 2910 0 entgegen